it is called the for the people act but
republicans are warning
it's actually a power grab by the
democrats the gop says this bill
sr1 would greatly expand the
government's role
in elections democrats say it will help
protect the right to vote for all
americans
the legislative battle ahead brought the
senate minority leader out today
to trade verbal blows with the majority
leader correspondent jackie heinrich is
following the action from capitol hill
rarely is a bill markup in the senate
rules committee the setting for
fireworks or even an appearance from a
party leader
i want to be very clear today stop
calling our democracy broken
but today both as democrats advanced a
sweeping election reform bill and
republicans drew
battle lines the eyes of history are on
all of you
the truth is quite simple our democracy
is not in crisis
democrats have made s-1 the for the
people act their top priority amid a
slew of new state election laws they say
restrict voting access especially for
people of color
framing it as 21st century jim crow
majority leader chuck schumer tied gop
opposition to the bill
to former president trump don't tell us
these laws are about voter fraud
everyone knows that donald trump
perpetrated the big lie but
unfortunately it seems the price of
admission
in today's republican party is silence
in the face of provable lies
minority leader mitch mcconnell shot
back calling it a politically motivated
federal takeover of the election system
for multiple years now democrats have
called this sweeping bill their top
priority this has gone from an election
security bill to an ethics bill
to a racial justice bill who knows what
it will be labeled
tomorrow the bill would dramatically
expand the federal government's role in
elections
creating automatic nationwide voter
registration and expanding early voting
among other things
republicans say it diminishes states
rights guts popular safeguards against
fraud like voter id
and tilts the power of the federal
elections commission but democrats are
urgently pushing forward while they
maintain
their narrow majority this is just the
beginning of a marathon
markup expected to continue tomorrow
republicans have
150 amendments filed but beyond that
its future is a lot less clear democrats
can't pass this unless they reform or
abolish the filibuster
allowing them to pass this along a party
line vote but moderate democrats
senators joe manchin and kirsten cinema
have said that they are against changes
to the filibuster and also want any
election reform
to be bipartisan brett jackie heinrich
live on capitol hill jackie thank